What we're looking for here is just the other x intercept of our new graph.
That's this point right here and its coordinates are 2, 0. So the water will
land 2 meters from the base of the fountain. Alternatively, we could have of
course figured this out from the equation alone. We can set up a quadratic
equation, 0 equals negative 7x squared plus 14 x, then I could just factor the
right side, which gives us 0 equals negative 7x times the quantity x minus 2.
This equation will be satisfied if either negative 7x equals 0 or if the
quantity x minus 2 equals 0. Of course, you get x equals 0 for the first
solution, which is the one we already knew ahead of time. And then, we get x
equals 2 for the second one, which is the one we just figured out.